if you're watching on Twitch hello
if you're watching in the future on
YouTube I'm actually recording this live
on Twitch
this is a present moment even though
when you maybe you're watching this
it'll be the past
but this is going to be episode 2 of the
speedrun
I've reconfigured the overlay a little
bit
I have a duck behind me who's
blindfolded who maybe doesn't want to
witness the destruction that's about to
happen
but the goal as usual is to be
instructive to try and just show what it
takes to be players at different rating
levels
I gained 47 points in the first two
games I played I'm 447. I'm not sure how
many games I'll play in this episode but
uh should be fun and
think we'll waste no more time let's hop
in
playing Ivan Nico
E4 rated just below 400
and I'm gonna play uh kind of the the
standard classical openings that I would
recommend for a player in this rating
level
um just to play normal chess King's Pawn
opening defend the pawn we have a Roy
Lopez
now against uh the Roy Lopez or the
Spanish
uh there's already a lot of moves back
can play
um A6 is by far the most common but
there's also Knight F6 which is called
the Berlin
um and then there's Sidelines to like D6
or G6 or 97. I'm gonna stick with like
the main uh the main approach challenge
the bishop
after the game I'll show what happens if
white wanted to snack the pawn
um but for now yeah Bishop A4 it's a
main line yeah for now what do I want to
do
I'm gonna play D6
this is a
more solid approach
just uh reinforcing E5
and yeah I don't want to be like overly
fancy in the opening so I'm just gonna
like go through with opening principles
trying Castle as quickly as possible
one of the downsides with D6 is it does
prevent the Bishop from coming to C5
but at the same time the bishop is
very fine here
um because it helps diffuse a potential
pin if uh if we do see Bishop G5
and so far my opponent is playing very
very well for for the reading like if I
didn't know the rating
um
I would maybe think that white could be
uh
could be at least 2 000 Plus
but sometimes this is common to see that
uh
players of this rating they'll they'll
play the opening fine and then make
mistakes later
so with this trade Bishop takes C6 Pawn
takes C6
uh I have double Pawns
which isn't um isn't always the best
thing like double pawns are notoriously
what
are notoriously powerful and causes
opponent to resign instantly
oh that's kind of disappointing
what happened to my opponent it wasn't
even like um a winning position like my
opponent clearly didn't rage resign or
rage quit
if anything like white is probably doing
fine do I have an eval bar
yeah the eval is just about equal
I was going to say that this this trade
probably favors black a little bit
because I get the bishop pair
which can be valuable long term and the
pawn coming closer to the center is is
quite nice
but um yeah I think I'll I'll hop into
another game shortly
I just want to provide one like very
basic
beginner lesson
in the Spanish
if you're playing this position as black
you should know what to do after takes
takes and takes
because this is something a lot of
beginners go for it looks like a free
Pawn for whites
I imagine there's a lot of people
watching on Twitch who know the move
if you're watching in the future on
YouTube and you don't know what to do
here it's a good time to pause the video
and try and find the best move for black
good job to a lot of people saying Queen
D4
this is one of these times that you can
basically make an exception to the
opening principle of um in this case
bringing out your queen early generally
you shouldn't bring out your queen early
but here there's a very good reason
attack the knighted attack the pawn
and uh black is guaranteed to win back
the pawn pretty much assuming light
saves the knights and take and this is
already much better for black because if
Queen E2 we're happy to trade two
Bishops pretty open position easy
development
White's King is on E2 which will
eventually be victim to a overcoming to
E8
so yeah it kind of breaks my heart that
we didn't get a full game and more
lessons but at least I can try and
provide a mini lesson
so
there's a question why why not Queen E7
Queen E7 is actually that's a good
question Queen E7 it's an attempt to win
back the pawn
but it runs into D4
and then black is kind of struggling to
regain material
and generally you don't want to play a
move like F6 which can be quite
weakening
like even
if you do win back the pawn in this case
this is a bit different because you
weaken yourself and White's developing
very rapidly
so I hope that makes sense I could keep
going down the rabbit hole another way
there's probably someone wondering about
Queen H5 check which would actually be
in Black's favorite because here here
black would win a piece
so yeah chess can be very complex
sometimes there's
multiple layers to go down in different
variations
but okay let's uh let's move on
and try and get another game against
someone who who wants to play
I know some people they start games and
then they get like a pizza delivery or
their parents call them downstairs for
dinner so
it's part of life so we have a Karo Khan
I'm gonna play uh
I'm gonna play an opening that I
recommend against Carol Khan It's called
the two nights attack
assuming
black plays D5 black doesn't play D5 so
I'm actually already in like unfamiliar
territory the Knight of six is
interesting it's like combining a
Carroll Khan
and an alkyne's defense
um sometimes the downside of 906 so
early is it walks into E5
and I think in this case E5 is the most
principled move like game Space attack
the Knight
and generally early on you don't want to
move
the same piece twice
because then it just slows down the
development of your other pieces
so my goal going forward is to improve
my position while attacking the knights
so like if the Knight moves here I can
kick it again with D3 it moves here I
can play H3
Knight D5 is probably the most likely
move
and then I can consider C4
or D4
opponent was taking their time
okay so we see 94.
and yeah we're gonna uh we'll play a
game of
of hacky sack just keep kicking the the
thing
keep making it move
a little bit of soccer
some people call it football
and this can already be like kind of
annoying for that to do it because
the lights almost trapped
interesting Queen A5
wow
okay I was not actually expecting that
move but that's that's interesting
because black is trying to provoke me to
play
a move to block the check with a minor
piece and if I block with any minor
piece Knight's ready to take
and I don't want to give black like an
easy route of kind of getting getting
the night off the board and being able
to trade it
so
I think it's probably best here to block
with the pawn
and this very simply gets out of check
and leaves back in the same predicament
now if we look a little bit further here
like again the Knight doesn't have too
many options I'm controlling these
retreating swears controlling G5
multiple times it looks like the only
safe square is C5
but with inclusion of Queen A5 if that
goes for this
then White's gonna have a move to
guarantee win either the Knight or the
queen
and I'll hold off on saying it until
until we see Knight C5
it's possible doc will do something else
yeah so the
the simple move to win material is a
pawn Fork
usually Knights are are the ones who are
like known to deliver the most Forks but
pawns are also pretty good at forking
and this is pretty much maximum
punishment for black disobeying a few
opening principles
they brought out the night into trouble
brought out the queen early and the the
pieces kind of instantly ran into the
the fork tactic
so showing no mercy here
won the night for the pawn
a queen still attacked
but the game goes on
and it's important in positions like
this to to not celebrate too early
still key principles in mind
King safety is important
the plan going forward is definitely to
bring in more pieces
I'll probably use a queen as a
as maybe a punching bag
I like this move C4
very simply attacking the queen
um
and the queen can't take the pawn
because my knight defends so
this move almost traps a queen
there is
as far as I could see there's only one
safe Square for the black queen
but I should address uh the pawn tension
too so that saves the queen
and now there are two attackers I only
have one Defender
and generally
I'll try and use this position as an
instructive moment because usually when
a pawn is attacking another Pawn you do
have a few choices
you can either take
or you can reinforce your own Pawn in
some cases you can push but not in this
case
another thing that comes to mind I think
this is really important to address is
that Queen and King are aligned on the
open file
so that makes me think about Rook E1
now as a question if I want to play
rookie one first or if I want to take
first
I think I actually want to take first
so I'm setting up a
small trap if black takes back with this
Pawn
then the queen and king
[Music]
are a lot more exploitable rookie one
would then pin the queens of the king
Pawn digs Pond seems like the most
natural move which opponent plays
so no mercy
I think we're gonna see this a lot in
like the early games of the speed run is
when
the queen and king for the opponent are
aligned usually you want to look for
ways to exploit them especially on the
open file
and this is one reason you want to
Castle early on you don't want your
kingdom to be a Target in the center so
open open files in the center are the
most likely to open
I should say the files in the center are
are the most likely to open early in the
game
okay so I was pretty quick 11 moves
I guess I should Define like assuming
there's a lot of like newer players
watching an open file is basically a
file with no pawns on it
there's also a half open file it's a
file with just one Pawn on it so the D
file is half open for whites
and generally early on you want to look
to put your Rooks on open files or half
open files
so okay I think that was that was pretty
instructive like showing how to just try
and punish these early night moves
basically improving while attacking is a
is a nice strategy
and I'm already like nearing this 500
rating mark
so I think I'll keep going until I hit
500 and then then maybe wrap it up for
episode two
so let's go again
playing I don't want to hurt myself
pronouncing this name
playing someone from Mexico
and yeah for a lot of the games that
these um like early rating levels I'm
gonna stick with just basic uh basic
openings
in this case we have a three nights
um I'll make it the Four Knights
when I was first learning chess like
almost every game I played would reach a
position very similar to this
and Bishop C4 it's one of the most
common moves
the lower level
and I think this will be a good example
to show
the center fork trick because even
though Bishop C4 it's like the most
natural looking move of course aiming at
the F7 Pawn
it's not a recommended move in this
specific position because of Knight
takes E4
and if you played this uh this Four
Knights from the lock side this is a
very useful idea as you keep in mind
because even though I just gave away a
night for a pawn
I'm winning it back
get the pawn Fork
and this is basically a fancy way of
trading pieces
because okay White's guaranteed to lose
either the neither the bishop
will likely get the pawn for it
and then it'll be equal material
but the reason why this is preferable
for black is
um it's going to lead to more central
control
and in this case it leads to me having
the bishop pair
which is very nice and a relatively open
position
after the game I can show some other
variations I know someone's asking about
Bishop takes F7 which it's definitely
important to address
but Knight C3 attacking the queen
there's a couple options for the queen
d8 is a perfectly fine move
I don't want to play a move like Queen
D6 or queen D7 because it blocks
with black one of the Bishops
I think the move I'll go for is Queen A5
I will say I usually go for Queen dates
but Queen A5 it's it's a little bit more
active
it is risky in the fact that I'm having
my queen out in the open maybe you could
run into like A3 B4 or D3 Bishop D2
but white can't exploit it right away
and thankfully this isn't spell chess so
opponent can jump over and take the
queen
and we see Pawn D4
interesting
so Pawn D4 that's a very confrontational
move
and one thing I'm like I'm noticing both
kings are are in the center and the
Center opens up it could get
uh tricky for both of us
and this is a case where
I have
I have a bunch of options there's
another good example of
when the pawn is attacking my Pawn I can
take
I could consider pushing because the
knight's pinned so it's not actually
controlling E4
or I could leave the tension and do
something else like Bishop G4 maybe or
Bishop B4
uh there's a lot of choices here
I definitely don't want to over
complicate things
the idea of taking is nice because
white has to take and then then I have
another move to dictate play
I could consider something like Queen E5
there
also in general I'm gonna go ahead and
take
there's a general principle is when you
have two Bishops
in this case it's two Bishops versus uh
Knight and Bishop
the two Bishops very much prefer open
positions
and the the more pawns that are traded
the more open the position becomes
especially when the center pawns are
traded
so do I take again and allow the Queens
to come in
I remember when I was like young and
first learning chess
I would make an effort to provoke my
queen or my puns Queen
out into the the center early in the
game because I thought it would be bad
for them to to have the queen in the
center but in this case if I take and
take the Queen's actually like pretty
powerful
and it's hard to exploit like takes
takes and then Bishop C5 runs into this
so I don't want to get tied down
I'm looking at the other options too
I mean queen E5 is interesting but Queen
E5 kind of just helps white develop
I'm spending a lot of time here
everyone's uh yeah everyone's playing
well for the reading at least so far
I have an idea to take take and then
Bishop E6 and then prepare Rook d8
even though my Bishop will be tied down
there will be ways to attack the queen
I think that's probably the simplest
line like relieve the tension right away
and then focus on development
I think a lot of players would make the
mistake of developing their dark Square
bishop and just forgetting about the
pawn
but it's so important like especially at
the lower levels before you make a move
you want to ask yourself if you're
leaving things undefended or exploitable
so in this case there's really nothing
white can try and exploit
and yeah let's get the Rook so the fully
open file
now I have some choices white could
force a queen shade Queen A4 was
possible
but I wouldn't mind like going into the
end game
uh now yeah now let's go for a bishop C5
it moves like rook d8 and Bishop C5 it's
what we call developing with tempo
or simply developing with attack
you improve a piece
you attack the opponents
and in doing so you gain time
because for a couple moves in a row
White's moving the queen rather than
developing the other pieces
and now this is very instructive I think
a lot of the players would just
instantly Castle they see their pawns
attacked
and um yeah castling looks like a very
very fine move
but it's so important to be tactically
alerts
and
know this the Queens are aligned
and unfortunately for my appointment
they walked into a pretty nasty uh
nasty idea Bishop takes off too
especially when the queen is
in the center and not defended you want
to look for ways to exploit it
and Bishop F2 comes with Chuck and now
the queen is lost
so no mercy
opponent played really well up until
allowing that and even the blunder was
not an obvious blunder by any means
okay so now
it's important to
take as much as I can and give nothing
back in return
like usually in real life you want to be
generous and kind to others
but in the chess game
it's okay to be greedy
no mercy
so pinning the The Rook
um I probably still want a castle it's
like the best way to get this Rook into
the game
also have to be aware of time
okay I'm taking more time than usual
just to try and explain things
a little bit more thoroughly
but there's no increments so
have to
have to watch the clock thank you
photochess for the raid
yeah for anyone just tuning in this is
uh one of the first games on my speedrun
account
this is going to be episode 2 of
the speedrun series for YouTube
um yeah let's get this Rook
to the open file even though the Rook is
blocked by the bishop we still consider
it an open file because once the bishop
moves and it has more scope to enter the
game and yeah positions when you're up a
lot of material in this case I'm up a
queen for a night
I'm really in no rush to try and
checkmates or even to try and win more
material I'm just improving my pieces
making making sure things will be ready
for
any um
any like confrontational moves
usually when your your pieces are on
good squares then tactics will be more
available
okay let's move the queen
let's move the queen to the
although if I play Queen H5 I I lose C7
okay let's move the queen to C6 save
move
attacking the Knight keeping the pawn
defended
maybe someday I can make use of the
light Square weaknesses in mites
kingside
okay yeah no Mercy Point s perhaps miss
the night was attacked
or maybe just wanted to deflect my queen
so they could win the pawn
Let's uh yeah let's save The Rook
and it's still a question how to like
orchestrate a checkmates
I really like my Bishop on H3
as it takes away the G2 Square
and at some point I'd like to
like crash through on the back rank
and probably to do that it requires
doubling of the Rooks you have two Rooks
on the same file then
it makes it easier to infiltrate
okay Queens attacked
let's go back to C6
threatening checkmates
earlier we saw my queen being attacked I
moved I moved to a square to attack
something else and my opponent missed it
really at the sub I'd say sub 800 level
players very often will miss the long
distance moves
so it requires having having board
Vision like the ability to see the whole
board
and for white there's not too many waves
to defend that is a way to defend
now I can stack the bishop
now this position actually brings back a
really painful memory
it was my second ever tournaments and I
had a position like this with the black
pieces like up a ton of things
I seemed like I was on my way to Victory
it was the second round of
I forget what city it was like a Chicago
area Scholastic tournament
and I was playing a four-year-old
like I took everything except one of his
Rooks
and what he ended up doing was back rink
checkmating me
like he got a situation his Rook came
down and even though I was up so much
material I just lost
I was so disappointing
not only to lose to a four-year-old but
to lose when up so much material
so we might see a white try to get the
rook in play
usually the the easiest way to avoid
back rank Mates is to make Luft
or make error for the king like move
move one of the pawns G6 or H6
give the king some breathing room
opponent doubles up
okay let's uh
let's come in here
now there's one legal move and
this will end the game so no mercy that
game
but big kudos to my opponent like
actually played a very fine opening
made me think a lot like I had some
interesting decisions in the the Early
Middle game
and then the the one tactical blender
was not obvious this uh I mean queen E5
looked like a nice centralizing move
just
wasn't aware of the the danger
on the fifth rank
so hey I crossed 500.
so let's end the video for YouTube
with some takeaway lessons from this
game
um
I know there are a lot of questions in
twitch chat about maybe the early stages
of the opening when you take on e4 there
are options for whites
and it's good to be prepared for what
white can do
I think a few people were asking about
Bishop takes F7 which when I was first
learning this opening from black I was
terrified of this move it looks scary
that white takes the pawn exposes a king
wins back the piece so it's equal
material here
the thing to understand about this
position is black is
actually much for choice
because the king isn't really a weakness
if white can't exploit it
and black is taking over the center with
Pawn D5
and even if white delivers a check the
king is going to hide on G8
I know it's ugly to maybe lose casting
rights but the King's Super safe here
moves like H6 and E4 are coming having
the bishop pair with two Sanger pawns is
a very good advantage
so
yeah Bishop S7 nothing to be afraid of
and then here
yeah there's a few other moves like a
lot of players will play Bishop B5 to
pin the knights
and then there's a useful idea that we
take the knights and if white takes back
it looks a little bit scary that the
knights attack twice and pinned
but here there's a very strong move
Queen D5
defending attacking attacking
and then black is also for choice in
this position
so
I don't want to make this episode too
long so I think I'll end it there if
people are watching in the future on
YouTube and you still have questions or
comments or feedback leave it below
don't forget to follow on Twitch
at least one person on Twitch says hi
YouTube so thanks for watching I'll see
you guys in episode three stay tuned